you talk about a movie star okay I am a
way better actor than I am a movie star
I was never ever comfortable I never had
a publicist uh I was never comfortable
on the red carpet I was into acting I
really cared about like my part and I
really wanted to do a good job and I
really cared about that but when it came
to like doing articles and magazines and
being on the cover of magazines and
stuff like that um you know and you can
go back and find me on the cover of Teen
Beat magazine or whatever like 50 years
ago or whatever and it's not like I ever
I never did it but I just wasn't that
good and I had a lifestyle that uh you
know thank God they didn't have phones